How do we control access to resources
with a context of authentication that
establishes a source and the idea
that these authorization check or
access control check has to happen if
the resources have to be protected.
Really, for us to be able to
answer this question we had,
whether a request should be granted or
denied,
we have to know who is allowed to access
what resources in a given system.
So if you think about this, there
are really two parts to this problem, or
the way we're going to
address this problem.
In part one, someone has to
specify who has access to what.
So this is called
an access control policy.
So there may be many ways to
decide who gets to access what.
There has to be a policy
we have in place
that is going to define this for us.
So to answer this question about who can
access what, is you tell the system how
the resources should be shared, or who
should be given access to what resource.
Once you do that, then it's
the part two is about enforcement.
The system has to monitor each
request for these resources, and
based on the policy that tells us who
can access what, it should make sure
any accesses that are allowed are
consistent with the policy that we have.
So enforcement basically says
there is no way for you to go and
access a resource when that access
is not allowed by the policy.
So define the policy that's in part one,
and then enforce the policy,
that's part two.
Now you can see the importance
of complete mediation.
Clearly complete mediation says,
no one should be able to bypass and
get to the resource without going
through the trusted computing base.
If you don't have complete mediation
then we can't perform this check,
access control check that
we are talking about.
That is possible only when the trusted
computing base is involved in a request
and that is why complete mediation is so
important.